um your links with the university stem
from a publication called babel
uh which is a language magazine that
you're the linguistic advisor i believe
on the publication that means i don't do
any work
not the real work the real work if
you've ever edited a magazine and i i
have it is a slog it is a real slog the
first issue is lovely because it's novel
and everybody's fresh it's when you get
to issue number five and six and fifteen
and sixteen that's when it gets tricky
now we've we've been wanting this
magazine the profession for decades
i first
had a discussion with publishers about
it oh back in the 1960s you know there
was a magazine called history today
um very important magazine and there was
no language today or linguistics today
or anything like that and yet language
studies is is the most perfect medium
for a magazine i think because languages
are people and so you take pictures of
people and what they do and all the
things they produce their writing
systems and the way they speak and so on
and it was so ready for a magazine you
know but nothing happened nothing
happened and then this wonderful
initiative from huddersfield here
uh when they first suggested it to me i
thought well all right it's going to be
a kind of magazine a bit like sort of
black and white full color
i mean it just jumped out at me i
thought this is the most amazing um
creative
design content everything came together
to produce something that is as the bbc
say really sexy
by which one means you know so
attractive to the general public that
you wonder why it was never done before
it's been a remarkable initiative and
for those people who
don't know much about it i mean even the
likes of stephen fry uh
hail the publication just just tell us a
little bit about what it's what it's
there to do and
it would appeal to yeah it's there
everybody is interested in language
there's no exception to that
anybody who ever listens to me now will
all they have to do is reflect on
oh their local place names and where
does that name come from you know or
we're going to name our child what's the
meaning of that child's name or they
don't speak like that round here that's
a funny accent you know everybody has
got an interest in language and so if
you have got that interest how are you
going to follow it up you see what do
you read i mean of course you read books
and things like that but magazines are
rather different i mean anybody who's
ever ever subscribed to a magazine and
and got into the magazine you're waiting
for the next issue because you you get
to know the writers you get to know the
subject you you go into it in a in a in
a way that is
relevant to the moment you know a book
that was written 10 years ago was
relevant to 10 years ago but these
magazines
keep you up to date and keep you in
touch with what's going on now several
of the articles in babel are about
things that have happened you know this
year or sometimes
last couple of months and so as a result
it gives you a kind of
access to the subject of language which
no other kind of mechanism provides and
this is what i've seen with the issues
of babel so far
i mean i know the subject as well as
anybody but i find myself learning new
things from the magazine you know
getting new perspectives that i didn't
have before i think it's available to
anybody with an interesting language
from the general public to the
specialist everybody will get some